y'a quelqu'un apparemment et ses liens
avec le tennis we say die avec le tennis
je pense là quelqu'un qui veut se
rapprocher de moi sachez que je vous
dise vous savez j'ai un entraîneur
s'occupe de quelqu'un de serena williams
et si j'ai le même entraîneur que serena
williams et s'appelle patrick moratoglou
j'ai vu qu'il y avait quelqu'un qui est
allé voir le match de serena williams la
finale perdue et je sens que elle et
elle y est allé pour me voir quoi si
vous savez les initiales serait pas mm
megan dans ce cas m adams un chocolat
champions dès qu'on comprenne c'est à
dire que vous vous pensez qu'une jeune
femme est allée à new york voir à voir
un match de tennis
juste pour que vous la voyez dans les
tribunes et que vous vous dites il ya
même un regard des gardes et gagnent un
peu moins voilà qu'à toi mais ça soit
moi vous kiffe la wii réveillez vous
pardon mais ce qui place évoquait elle
est à côté de mon entraîneur c'est
évident mais du nord
on a besoin d'eux
[Applaudissements]
ça ce serait flagrant si elle avait
parlé de vous à votre humeur mais si
elle ne dit rien alors que c'est très
simple et chérie en deux coups de fil je
la touche back s'appelle bob babbitt
mouratoglou qui me donne son numéro je
l'appelle
cette année
elle au téléphone par direct dans les
médias alors c'est le respecte alors je
peux l'a touché en deux fois aussi de
l'ormeau elton john meghan markle c'est
vrai alors est ce que vous voulez je
vous dis là où je vous le dis avant la
fin de la semaine
j'aurais meghan markle au téléphone est
résigné pas l'aspect moutons détroit
galère cas parce que vous faites merkel
tu n'auras jamais
[Rires]
vous voulez vraiment que les relations
entre la france et la grande bretagne
devienne excécrable beaucoup déjà qu'on
a des problèmes avec le brésil non mais
à toi tu as très plaisir tout cas un mec
appellent damas à déposer ses vous oui
ça fait la paix ap le cocu magnifique